[MUSIC PLAYING]
THIJS VAN AS: Good
afternoon, everybody.
My name is Thijs van As, and
I'm a product manager for Gmail.
And today I'm very
excited that we're
announcing a completely new
way of integrating your app's
functionality right into Gmail
right when the user needs it
most.
And not just on Gmail for web,
but also natively on Android
and on iOS.
And how this works, I'll tell
you later during the session.
And I'm super
excited that it's not
just me talking about
Gmail add-ons today.
But we actually have three
of our very valuable partners
with me today that
will be showing off
a demo of the
add-ons that they've
been building over the past few
weeks using this new framework.
I'll introduce them to you
later during the session.
First, let's start taking a
look at this big shift that's
been happening in application
software recently,
and it's called the cloud.
Specifically when we
look at the workplace,
we see that there's all
these types of software,
like project management,
CRM, invoicing,
and it's all moving
into the cloud,
if it's not there already.
And now let's take a
look at how email behaves
in this space between all these
different types of productivity
software.
For many of us, email
is the central place
where stuff happens at work.
Whether it's good or
bad, email is basically
a task list for us.
And for most of us, this means
that we're switching constantly
between Gmail and other types
of productivity applications.
For example, if
I'm a marketer, I'm
switching between
Gmail and Marketo.
If I'm an HR person,
I'm switching
between Gmail and LinkedIn.
Or if I'm a
salesperson, I switch
between my CRM and Gmail.
And as you've heard this morning
during Prabhakar's keynote,
G Suite is not just a
random bunch of apps.
No, it's actually a very
thoughtful workforce platform
where each and
every individual app
is meant to work
very well together.
And there's a lot
of deep integrations
between the
individual Gmail apps,
which we're launching
more and more.
And we recognize that people are
not just using Gmail apps or G
Suite apps at work.
They're using all these other
apps that we just talked about.
And that's why we
acknowledge that G Suite
apps need to work very well
with all the other cloud
applications.
We all know this, right?
It's a pain.
For me, my browser
tabs, they're often
so narrow that I don't
even see the icons anymore.
And it really drives
the point home.
Switching contacts is a pain.
And let's not even start talking
about how it is on mobile.
Because on mobile, I mean, even
if you have installed the app
already, it's just annoying.
And we all know that we're doing
more and more on our phones.
When we look at
this graph, we see
that the number of
emails that we're opening
is a lot more mobile
than on desktop.
And what's even
more apparent here,
is that the rate this increases
is much stronger on mobile.
And that's why we're
introducing Gmail Add-ons today,
a new extensibility framework
to integrate your app's
functionality into
Gmail right when
the user needs it most,
natively on Android and on iOS
and on web.
Without further
ado, let me show you
a demo of what this
actually means.
Could we switch
to the Chromebook?
The other screen on
the Chromebook please.
OK, let me set it straight.
It's fixed.
Not a problem.
All right, so what we're looking
at here, this is my mailbox.
And I cleaned it
up for the moment.
And you see I have an email
from my coworker, [? Ernesta ?]
and it is the subject,
catching up over coffee.
So let's take a look at it,
what she's actually asking.
So she asked me,
hey, do you have
time to catch up over coffee?
I'm available at
3:00 PM next Friday.
And she sent this a
few days ago to me.
So now, if we look at the
right-hand side of the screen
here, we see an icon, and this
is the Google Calendar icon.
It's in black and white though.
And this is the
Google Calendar add-on
that we built together with the
team as an initial prototype
to show what the power
is of these add-ons.
So this add-on, it
triggered for this email
because [? Ernesta ?]
asked me if I'm
available to meet with her.
So now when I tap on this
icon, a panel comes up.
And what it does,
it shows me what
is my agenda for the
moment or for the day where
she asked me to meet.
So in this case, she asked
me to me at Friday, tomorrow.
So it shows me what is
my agenda for tomorrow.
And so I have a couple of
events already, and from here,
it shows me whether I'm busy or
I'm free at the specific time.
In this case, I'm busy.
And in fact, I'm busy
with the same event,
catching up over coffee, because
I did this demo 20 minutes ago,
and I forgot to clean it up.
But that's nice,
because we actually
showed that it's
actually really working.
So what I can do from
here, I can actually
send her a new
invitation or I can just
open up the thing
in Google Calendar
and from there do something.
So now I want to show
you that I can actually
create an invitation,
but I'm not
going to show that
on the desktop,
I'm going to show
that on the phone,
because a key part of
the add-ons framework
is that it's cross-platform.
So if you could please
switch the Android phone?
Now we're looking
at my same inbox.
No, that's the wrong device.
It's open.
If you could switch
to the iPhone,
I can do it on the iPhone,
because it's cross-platform.
All right, so here
we are on the iPhone.
And so I opened up
the same message.
See here, same email.
In the bottom right
corner of my phone,
I see the same
Google Calendar icon.
So when I tap on it, you
see the exact same UI
as we just saw a moment ago
on web, natively rendered.
So it shows my
agenda for Friday.
It shows it like split screen,
so I can see both the message
content, and I can see the
content the add-on provides me.
In this case, I want
to see it a bit bigger,
so I'm making the
add-on full screen.
And now let's continue.
The demo I actually wanted to
show you is creating an event.
So I tap on the
create event button.
It will take me to a
new screen, and you
see that there are a lot of
the event details are already
automatically filled out by
the Google Calendar add-on.
So you see there's a
title that's suggested,
the guests or the participants
already filled out,
and the dates and the time.
Now I can add a location to
the event or a description.
In this case, I'm
not going to do that.
But I am going to toggle
sending invitations,
because then [? Ernesta ?]
will know that I actually
wanted to meet with her.
So now I press Save, and
I get a confirmation.
When I tap on View
Event, it will open up
in a Google Calendar app.
In this case, no
real need for that.
So I just tap OK, and then I
get a confirmation over here.
Can we go back to the slides?
So this was a nice demo of
an integration between Google
Calendar and Gmail.
But what I'm even
more excited about
is that some of our
partners have been building
even better integrations.
And I'd like to introduce
Ursula Shekufendeh, a product
manager at ProsperWorks,
to show off
the demonstration of the
add-on that they have built up
over the past weeks.
[APPLAUSE]
URSULA SHEKUFENDEH: Thank you.
Can we get the Pixel
device to show?
My name is Ursula,
and for those of you
who are not familiar
with ProsperWorks,
we are a CRM solution,
born to address
the problem of complexity with
CRM by focusing on automation
and ease of use.
And two ways we were able
to accomplish that actually
involves Google.
So we were able to integrate
with the G Suite apps
and we also adopted
material design,
which gives our users
the look and feel
that they're so familiar with.
So we are actually recommended
in the G Suite marketplace.
The Google teams actually
are using ProsperWorks.
We love everything Google,
especially the Pixel,
so I'm glad it's showing up.
Am I using the iPhone instead?
All right, first
time on the iPhone.
I really do prefer the Pixel.
And we were really excited when
we learned about this project.
So we were thrilled
to jump in, and I'm
going to show you what
we've been working on.
Great.
So I'm going to pretend
just for you today
that I'm a salesperson.
And I'm on my way, en route to
see a customer to show a demo.
And what I'm going to do is
actually open up an email
that I just happened to receive
from that very customer.
Hey, Ursula, I wanted
to let you know
that Brian Crushing, a former
colleague of mine who is also
looking for a similar
solution for his business,
will be joining
our meeting today.
Great.
Sounds like a new lead.
What am I going to do?
Am I going to mark
the email as unread
and then wait to add it
into my system later?
No.
I could open up the ProsperWorks
app and then add that lead.
But as you probably
see coming, there's
a way easier way to do that now.
I can actually just tap
on the ProsperWorks logo
here on the bottom right
corner, and it pulls up
all of the contacts that are
included in that email thread.
So there's myself,
Ursula, the system user.
There's Ben, who's
my contact, and then
Brian Crushing, who was
copied on the email.
And if I select Brian, I can
actually expand this card
and get a full view, and
I get all the information
that ProsperWorks was able to
gather about that contact based
on the email address.
And I can add that
person as a lead.
There we go.
So I have that lead.
I don't have to worry about
it again until ProsperWorks
reminds me later that I need
to follow up, and I'm done.
So now I'm going to focus on
my meeting that's coming up,
and I want to do a very
good job on my demo.
And what I do for
that is actually
look into Ben's information.
I can get the full details of
that contact from ProsperWorks,
and I can look at
activity, so interactions
that I've had with this
prospective client in the past,
be it notes that I made or
calendar events or phone calls
that I've had with this person.
I can see here on the top
note, these are the things
that he cares
about, so I'm going
to be sure to touch on those
when I meet with him in person
and look totally prepared.
I can also see any related
items to that contact,
including the opportunities,
tasks and calendar.
And let's say maybe I want
to dig a little deeper
and look at more--
ah, this one is not set up.
But I could deep links actually
into the ProsperWorks app,
which means that I don't have
to open up the app, search
for that contact, and
waste time doing so,
switching to different apps
from the mobile device,
as Thijs was explaining.
It's a little cumbersome.
I can actually just do
it right from the add-on.
It will take me straight
to the opportunity record
and show me any details.
So I went into the demo,
it went great, so flawless.
And I want to maybe write
a quick thank-you note
to the client.
And while I'm in
Gmail, I might as well
also log a note here and
make a note of the meeting
that I just had.
I'm going to say
demo went great.
And maybe got round
of applause maybe.
[APPLAUSE]
And then I'll save.
And you'll notice
the activity is now
associated to that contact,
and I'll see the same activity
across all platforms.
So the apps, the web
app, and I'm done.
And I know that
our customers will
be chomping at the bit,
won't be able to wait
to get this functionality.
They're going to be
probably as excited
as we were to work on this.
And I want to give a shout out
to Steve Holm and Ben and Eric,
who have worked on this.
And a huge thank you
to Thijs and his team
for making this tool
available, which
will make our users'
lives so much easier.
[APPLAUSE]
THIJS VAN AS: Can we
switch back to the slides?
Thank you very much,
Ursula, and also thank you
for being flexible and doing
the demo on a different device.
Great, so when we
think about what
was the reason why we
introduced Gmail add-ons,
it's all about making our
users more productive,
helping them waste
less time in Gmail.
And we did this by bringing
you, by bringing them
your app's functionality
close to where they need it.
And we do this by showing
those add-on icons in the UI
for each message
where it's relevant.
Now, there's, of
course, a risk here,
because this might
result in like a wildfire
of different icons
for different add-ons.
So what we did is we built
the framework in such a way
that you can trigger
your add-on when
it's contextually relevant.
So for example,
the Google Calendar
add-on that you
just saw, it's only
triggered for an
email that contained
an intent from the sender
to set up a meeting.
It doesn't just trigger
if the meeting contains
a data or a time mentioned.
There's actually
an intent behind it
when the user wants to,
when the sender of the email
wants to meet.
Now, I want to reiterate that
it was very important for us
to make this cross-platform,
because we realized
there were some options today
to extend Gmail on the web,
but given the rise
of mobile usage,
we wanted to make sure this
was desktop and mobile.
Now with that, we realized
there was not a good development
pattern today to do this
on [INAUDIBLE] mobile,
and especially not
doing it efficiently
without a lot of hassle.
So we started thinking about
a new development paradigm
for these Gmail add-ons.
And first of all, Gmail add-ons,
they're written in Apps Script.
If you're not familiar
with App Script,
Apps Script is a
JavaScript runtime
in the cloud specifically built
for integrating and enhancing
G Suite applications.
So with tons of APIs to
integrate with other G Suite
apps, like it's very easy to
build like a quick integration
with Google Drive, Google
Calendar, and Google Docs,
for example.
And it's also super easy
to hook up your own APIs
into Apps Script.
You could already built Google
Docs add-ons with Apps Scripts,
but now today you can
also build Gmail add-ons.
However, this doesn't
say anything yet
about how does this
cross-platform.
And for that, we built a new
design system using cards.
So let me walk through
that with an example.
So what you're looking at
here is like an example add-on
that we called Contacts.
And what it does, it
shows for all the people
in an email conversation,
it will show me
some contact information
coming from my address book.
And by means of this
add-on, I'm going
to tell you what the card
system actually means.
So in this case, all the
information for one contact
is all on one card.
Now a card consists of a couple
of individual components.
So there's a header of the card.
In this case, the header
contains the profile picture
of the sender, and it contains
the name of the contact.
And there's a couple
of other variations
that we have, but
here's an example.
Then a card contains
one or more sections.
And in these sections,
you basically
combine your
different UI elements.
And for these UI elements,
we call them widgets here.
Here's an example of
a widget, so where
we show the email
address of the sender.
Currently, we have
a whole library
available of UI
widgets, anything
from interactive widgets
like text inputs,
dropdowns, checkboxes to
information representation
widgets, like
images, paragraphs,
and label description
[INAUDIBLE].
And sometimes your add-on, it
needs to return multiple cards
to the user.
So in the case of
this Contacts app,
we might want to show
a card for each person
in the conversation,
also the people that
are cc'd, for example.
And in that case, what
our system will do
is it will collapse the
multiple cards that you
have into one overview.
And then the user can
tap on an individual card
to expand it and
basically do a deep dive.
And that's, for example,
what you saw just
in the ProsperWorks
add-on just a moment ago.
All right, so that's
the card system.
But it's still
pretty high level.
So how does this look in code?
I want to show you
that by means of a very
tiny, simplified example.
So I made the Contacts
example even simpler.
So super tiny card
with just a header
with one section that
contains just the email
address of the sender and
the section as a header.
So let's look at how
this looks in code.
As a first step, we're creating
a new instance of a card
by calling the
createCard method.
Now we're giving this card
a header, because every card
needs a header.
And in that header, we're giving
it two pieces of information.
In this case, the profile
picture of the sender and also
the name of the sender.
And as I mentioned
before, there's
a bunch of other variations.
You can leave out the picture.
You can add some other lines of
text, but this is basically it.
Now we're adding a
section to this card.
And in that section, we can use
it to put UI widgets in there.
But first, before
adding UI widgets,
we want to give this
section a title or a header.
That's optional,
but in this case,
we're calling it Contact Info.
And now let's create
our one and only UI
widget, which in this
case, we use the key value
widgets, which is
pretty generic.
It's a way to create [? pairs ?]
of a label and a description.
In this case,
we're using an icon
as a label, the email icon, and
we're using the email address
as the description.
But there's a bunch
of other variations.
It's quite flexible.
So as you see here, this is
quite a short piece of code,
of course, also quite
a simple add-on.
But it's really simple,
and the magic here
is this translates
into a nice UI,
fully material design, not just
on one platform, but on three.
And you've already seen
the demo on a Chrome device
and on an iPhone.
And hopefully the next demo we
will do on an Android device.
And with that, I'd
like to introduce
Krzysztof Oblucki,
who is a software
engineer at Salesforce.
And he will show
you a demo that he
built for a Salesforce add-on.
[APPLAUSE]
KRZYSZTOF OBLUCKI: Hi, my
name is Krzysztof Oblucki.
I'm an engineer at
Salesforce, and I'm
going to show you the stuff
that we've built with Google
in the past couple of weeks.
It's pretty exciting.
I'm going to go into my
Gmail, switch to my account
here, awesome.
And essentially, our use case
is very similar to ProsperWorks.
We want to make sure that
our salespeople and sales
guys have a much easier time
getting information queried out
of Salesforce, creating
records inside Salesforce
without having to go and
break out into a browser
and being able to essentially
do most of the stuff
that they would do there
directly through the add-on
and through this framework.
So there is a list of
emails that I have.
You can imagine those being like
business-related emails where
I would like to pull
in some context based
on the information there.
So I can click on
the Salesforce cloud
here and expand
[? the ?] add on.
And there we go.
There's a list of people that
were queried out of Salesforce
based on the email
addresses that we
have collected from Gmail
and from the message itself.
So here's a list of them.
Those are the matches
that we've come up with.
So I'm going to pick one,
for example, Marina here.
And in there, kind of
like the information
that we can look up,
are just email address,
location, phone numbers.
But on top of that, we can also
look up some of the activities
that the person has been up to.
So things are open, the
history of activities
that they have done so far based
on the business that they're
looking for, and
also opportunities,
so global media
distribution rights
and all sorts of
different things
are related to that
particular object in CRM.
So that's pretty cool.
You can also break out
viewing in Salesforce.
He can take this
and break out to do
more complex set of things
inside the browser itself
or inside the native app.
So having said that,
there's other things
you can also do besides
doing that, which
is logging emails
into Salesforce, which
is a pretty interesting
feature to our users
specifically, which
allows you to take
the content of the
message, put it
inside Salesforce as
different types of object,
whether it's a task
or an email item,
and then provide
some sort of context
into who it's associated to.
So those things are important
for sales guys specifically
when they're trying
to do essentially
log and relate
information together
to make some sense out of it
towards the end of the quarter.
So you can select a task as the
target object to relate it to.
You can pick, let's
say, I don't know,
Marina as the
person that is going
to be the who on the object.
And you can also
select things that
maybe are not in the
list of current contacts.
So most of the information
that you see there listed
came from the emails
that were on the message.
So if a person has an
account associated with it,
it's also pulled down.
But that's not everything
that you can pull down.
You can, for example, search
for something specific
that is not listed there.
So Salesforce is a
pretty generic thing
that should return
a bunch of records.
So I'll go through
that, click on Search.
That's going to expand the
list to things like leads.
We have some leads there.
We have accounts.
We have more opportunities.
So that will serve
as, for example,
the what entity on
the task object.
So I will select
the opportunity,
Salesforce 500 widgets.
And then up top, the
whole thing updates.
So whenever you leave
this and then come back,
you can essentially look
back at this information
and pull out all
the contacts that
was saved there the last
time that you've done that.
And that's part of the demo.
The really cool thing for me
from an engineering perspective
is that it really took a
very short period of time
to do all this stuff.
I mean, it literally from
nothing to what we see there,
it took about five days.
And it's pretty polished.
There's a lot of stuff
there that's pretty cool.
It fits very well with
what we offer at Salesforce
with our existing integrations.
And it's on mobile, and
it's in the browser.
It's really awesome.
From my perspective, it was kind
of nice to build this that way.
And all the material-UI
is all built in there.
You don't have to fiddle
with other things,
it's all pretty much there.
Oh, there's the GitHub thing
I accidentally clicked on.
Anyway, so, yeah,
really cool stuff.
We want to thank Thijs for
letting us do all this stuff,
and I'll pass the
mic over to you now.
[APPLAUSE]
THIJS VAN AS: Krzysztof,
super awesome demo,
and I'm really
impressed with how
he built that whole add-on
in just a matter of a week,
fully functional.
So kudos for that.
All right, so can we
switch back to the slides?
Want to look at what does
this mean for our users now?
And it basically means that all
the apps and productivity tools
that you guys have
built already can now
be brought to them right at
their fingertips at the place
really need it most,
at any platform where
they might use Gmail.
And this will basically
cause them to waste less time
and be more productive.
Gmail add-ons will be
available through the G Suite
marketplace.
This is a marketplace
where you're currently
able to get, for example,
Google Docs add-ons.
And the G Suite marketplace
will be available
or will be accessible
from within the Gmail app.
And you can there
discover the add-ons
that might be relevant
for your use cases.
And Gmail add-ons will be
available for both consumer
users, as well as for
enterprise users, of course.
So what does this
mean for developers?
Well, we just showed you that
we have a very new development
framework based around
these cards that
allows you to build
cross-platform add-ons
for Gmail, not worrying about
what platform the user might
on.
And it brings you
the opportunity
to bring your app or
your app's functionality
to the user in the right
context where they need it most.
And with that, I'd like to
introduce our last partner.
Devana Bhargava
from Intuit, and she
will show you what
they've built.
[INAUDIBLE]
DEVANA BHARGAVA: Can we
switch to the iPhone, please?
All right, hi, everyone
I'm Devana Bhargava.
I'm a product manager at
Intuit working on invoicing.
And to walk you through
this demo today,
I'm going to give
you a perspective
from a small business owner.
So I'm a small
business owner who
owns a catering company
called Catering by Devana.
Very original, I know.
As the owner, I
run the day-to-day,
which means anything from
cooking to catering events
to managing our finances.
We've been growing
a lot recently,
which is really exciting,
but at same time that
means that we have
a lot more customers
and so I need to
create more invoices.
Invoicing is a pretty tedious,
but also time consuming job.
And so I usually end up doing
invoicing on my weekends
when I have a little
bit more free time.
Invoicing right
now and in the past
has for me been
creating a document,
entering it in with the
items and the services
that we've provided, and
then saving as a PDF,
attaching it to an email.
And then after that, I
have to manually enter
in and track who's paid
me and who hasn't paid me.
Then I have to send reminders,
so it's a pretty tedious effort
today.
But I recently discovered
this awesome add-on
called QuickBooks
Invoicing inside of Gmail.
It lets me invoice my customers
directly inside of Gmail, which
is really awesome, especially
because I use Gmail
to run my entire business
and as my primary way
to communicate
with my customers.
So I'm just going to walk
you through exactly how I
would create an invoice.
Sarah Hill is a
brand new customer,
and we just finished
a catering event
for her son's birthday party.
So I need to send her an
invoice so that I can get paid.
And usually in the
past, this would
have taken me about 15 to
20 minutes per customer.
So now it's gotten really fast.
I need to click on the
QuickBooks Invoicing icon
at the bottom right.
Expand it and create
a brand new invoice.
Sarah's information has
already been pre-filled,
because QuickBooks knows that
I've been emailing with her.
All I need to do is
include the service
that we provided for her,
which is a birthday party.
QuickBooks also knows
that in the past
we've done birthday parties,
and that we charge about $600
per event.
And so it's pre-filled
that for me as well.
I can also see a
preview of the invoice
before sending it to Sarah.
This is exactly what Sarah
will see when she gets
the invoice from QuickBooks.
I love that I don't
have to do anything,
and it's beautiful
and professional.
So I'm just going to make sure
that this is the right invoice.
It has $600 and
a birthday party.
So I'm going to go ahead
and send it to her.
Invoicing is so much easier.
And I can even do it
while I'm on the go.
I no longer need to set
aside time on my weekends
to invoice my customers.
I can also see all
the different invoices
that I've sent in the past to
check if customers have paid me
or not.
So going to click
on View Invoices.
Awesome, Devon
James paid me $1,500
for an engagement party that
we did a couple of weeks ago.
And in that meantime,
if I scroll up,
Sarah Hill's already viewed the
invoice that I just sent her.
With QuickBooks Invoicing
inside of Gmail,
I can now have all
the tools that I
need to run my business
in one place, which
means that I can spend more time
doing the things that I love
within running my business.
So thank you.
And if you have any
questions about how
we built it or
QuickBooks Invoicing,
please come visit booth A16.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
THIJS VAN AS: Thank
you very much.
I'm super excited
how QuickBooks now
makes it possible that small
business owners can quickly
send invoices right
from their mailbox.
It's really nice.
Can we please switch
back to the slides?
So now the big question, when
is this all coming available?
So Gmail add-ons will be
available for all consumer
users and for all enterprise
users later this year.
But as of today, you can sign
up for the developer preview.
Which means that you will get
early access to all those APIs,
and that you can also
start building add-ons just
like our partners
here showed us.
If you go to g.co/GmailAddOns
you can sign up right now,
and we hope to start sending
invitations very soon.
I'm super excited about
what we've seen today
and what the opportunities
are of this framework
in the future.
And I hope you are too.
I can't wait to see what you all
will be building in the future.
And I want to thank
our partners very much
for the work over
the past months.
I think their add-ons
are fantastic,
and I want to give them
another round of applause.
And thank you, too.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]